تقنيات لاكثر لحظات الحياه اثاره فشركه
جوجل تراهن كثيرا على نظارتها الجديده
التي تعتبر كمبيوترا ملبوسا مع كاميرا
مدموجه وسيمكن التقاط مقاطع فيديو وصور
بها وهذا كله جزء من صيحه جديده تدعى
التقنيه الملبوسه وهي اكثر الصيحات تصاعدا
منذ الهواتف الذكيه وصيحه الساعات الذكيه
بدات بالانتشار في الاسواق
الان حتى بعد ان انتقدت شركه فنتر كابيتال
مبدئيا ما اصبح اكثر منتجات التقنيه
اثاره من اين اتت فكره الساعه
الذكيه اتت الفكره عندما كنت امارس رياضه
ركوب الدراجات كان الهاتف في جيبي واردت
رؤيه من تحدث
معي هذا هو ايريك ميكون سكي مبتكر ساعه
بيبل وقد تكون اشبه بنموذج قديم لساعه
كاسيو ولكنها رمز لساعات
المستقبل ومن الصعب التصديق ان كونكي
وشركته الصغيره طورت الساعه داخل هذا
المبنى
الصغير الساعه تعمل من خلال الاتصال
بهاتفك عن طريق البلوتوث ويمكنك رؤيه جميع
الاتصالات الوارده والرسائل على الساعه مع
امكانيه التنبيه بالاهتزاز وهذا مفيد عند
صعوبه الوصول الى
هاتفك اخراج الهاتف قد يكون غير مريحا
احيانا وربما يشكل خطرا ايضا ويستحسن رؤيه
الرسائل من خلال الساعه وكان انتقاد لساعه
خط
كبيرا وكان هذا واضحا عندما قام ميكون سكي
بجمع التبرعات لمشروعه على موقع كيك
ستارتر المشروع كان على موقع كيك ستارتر
لمده 30 يوما وتمكننا من جمع اكثر من 10
ملايين
دولار وليس مستغربا في المستقبل القريب ان
نرى الكثير من الاشخاص يصطفون في طوابير
طويله لشراء مثل هذه الصيحات
التقنيه